Why don't we start, Jai? Do you want to start? Each of you
give you a little brief intro overview of your journey and
entrepreneurship, and then we will launch into this very
pressing - oh, yes, please, our cell phones need to be off.
We are taping so cell phones interfere with the
transmission. So if you can please turn your phones off,
that would be hugely helpful. So thank you. I have Nancy
here to keep me honest. Jai, you want to start?
Sure. My name is Jai Prakash graduate from the GSB last year
in June. And so my journey to entrepreneurship, I started -
prior to the GSB, I spent a few years in consulting in
sports and a couple years of private equity. And so I came
to the GSB thinking I want to do something more
entrepreneurial. And I used my summer between my first and
second year to work at - I started to call Bonobos which was
started by some GSB of '07. You guys have probably seen e-
mails about it by now. I really enjoyed that, came back my
second year deciding I wanted to do something that was very
entrepreneurial and focusing on its products, spent a lot of
company meeting with different companies that came with
different ideas of my own, and ended up at a company called
reBloom which right now, I am the COO, I was employee #2.
The product launched in May, and we sell it two and half
ounce natural sleep drink that's an alternative to things
like Ambien
[inaudible] and so. I started in July, and I have been there
for nine months.
So my name is Ilana Stern. I am the founder and CEO of
WeddingtonWay which is an online boutique for bridesmaid
dresses. It's basically essential shopping for bridal
parties. I was a buyer for Bloomingdale's prior to the GSB
and came in sort of knowing that I was passionate about the
fashion industry and fascinated by a lot of the
inefficiencies in the industry but not sure yet what I
wanted to do about it. Basically, I started working on the
idea for WeddingtonWay in the summer between my first and
second year. A lot of actually time spent with Jai, we
shared an office at Bonobos for a couple of weeks during the
summer. And I actually did it something different than Jai,
which is spent part of the summer in consulting and part of
the summer at Bonobos. Half of my time at Bonobos was spent
doing project for them and half of it was spent doing a
project for myself. And basically, it just got going in the
second year with WeddingtonWay, took advantage of the time
at the GSB to do a massive amount of consumer research. It
was really the most important thing for us to understand
where the pain was coming from with brides in the process,
and incorporated WeddingtonWay in May of my second year, got
our first commitments from investors the week of graduation
and started full time really the day after graduation.
So my name is Alex Salazar. I am a GSB-09 my company is
called Katasoft, and we are making application security
software. So we are trying to make application security
easy. And our projects base on open source project that we
also have called Apache Shiro. So we are very much in the
enterprise software space. My background prior to the GSB
was enterprise sales for IBM, so I have always lived in
enterprise software. While at the GSB, I was very busy. I
ran the E-Club along with Daniel who is not here right now,
and I also put together the E-Conference. And it was a great
time. My summer interest was in venture capital, also folks
in enterprise software. And then I spent my second year
flushing out of thesis around Cloud software, tried to start
a company based off that. That company wasn't not working
out, and then a few months later, ended up finding this
opportunity and started this company with a different
partner, which took about nine months after graduating.
The first prescribed question we have is about what you
didn't take advantage of the business school. But these
three student alums I think were particularly good about
taking advantage of many things at the business school. So
in addition to talking about what you wish you take an
advantage of, how much you guys in particular just talk
about what you didn't take advantage of because they were
really full-time residents in the CES. So one or the other
way, Alex, maybe you talked about it a little bit.
So I took advantage of everything I could get my hands on.
The CES was ground zero. I spent I think at least twice two
days a week just at the CES with Lynda, with Nancy and just
using that as kind of my headquarters for all the work I was
doing. I also really leveraged the network that the school
has. I mean when you are a student, you have access to
everyone. Anyone and everyone will take your call; anyone
and everyone will give you time; anyone and everyone will
tell you information they shouldn't give you. And so I took
advantage of that fantastic network of people that have
really, really helped and some of which have financed our
company. And I also participated in everything the
Entrepreneurship Club had which also gave me a very strong
network of fellow classmates and alums who were also
entrepreneurs, which has been probably one of the most
important things in the first year in just helping to stay
same, is having people around and going the same --
Is there anything that you think you missed?
Yes. So the flipside to that equation was that I had no
spare time while I was in school, and that actually from an
entrepreneurship standpoint was difficult because I didn't
have a lot of free time to really evaluate ideas in the
capacity that I should have been evaluating them when I was
in school, and I didn't have the opportunity to really just
spend time working on concept and testing them while a
student. I had to actually wait until I graduated and then
had spare time to go do that work. In hindsight, it would
have
[inaudible] with the working wife, yeah.
So I think we are probably all going to echo each other to a
certain perspective. But essentially, for me, I think the
most beneficial thing was really getting out there, talking
to alums, talking to people connected with community,
investors, other entrepreneurs and just getting a lot of
feedback on the idea as it was evolving. And there was sort
of nothing more beneficial from just a testing the idea
perspective, from the building confidence perspective,
learning how to talk to other entrepreneurs, learning how to
talk to investors and really sort of getting hang of how
everything works.
Can you talk about how you either did or did not do that in
the context of class as well?
Yeah. So okay, so that's a good point. So I would say what I
wish I had done more of actually is taking more
entrepreneurial classes earlier. Our first year was a little
bit less flexible in terms of extra classes we could take
[inaudible]. But I did get a massive amount out of it. So I
took 356 in my second year, and we developed a lot of what
WeddingtonWay is through the 356 class. That was huge, just
getting other students involved in the idea, seeing like
learning how to excite a team, how to pitch every other
week. It was just incredibly valuable, formation of new
ventures, MGE with Joel Peterson, another phenomenal class
and just a lot of the classes where it's just sort of throw
away the cases and really dig into a real business idea, do
role playing where you are really sort of stepping outside
your comfort zone. I think a lot of entrepreneurship is
doing things you don't know how to do every single day. And
you have - a lot of the entrepreneurial classes really
helped me sort of step outside of my comfort zone and keep
pushing myself to the next level, so that I really sort of
became conditioned and got totally used to it.
So what did you miss or what you wish you had done?
Yeah. So I mean just I think getting sort of - I think the
biggest thing I didn't do was there was so much benefit in
reaching out to the '09 network in my second year, the
network around Stanford. And I wish I had done more pf that
my first year. So I guess this is a little bit more relevant
for first years. Just started finding excuses to reach out
to alums as early as you can and just start figuring out how
to engage people in conversation. It's really beneficial
early on.
Jai.
Yeah. So things I did that were good, I think so I am
talking about classes, the three classes that I took that
are probably the most valuable for me right now are MGE,
well I think it goes back - I think when I took it, I
thought it was like okay, when I am running a company 10
years from now, I will use these things. But the lessons you
learn, they come up in everyday conversations with vendors,
with hiring, with whatever. And so it's been super valuable.
Touch-feely is an amazing class, so I think everyone should
try and take it your first year here. You still have the
chance to sign up. And then 356 I took which was just a
startup class and so I didn't have an idea that I had - I
wanted brand new, I wanted the consumer products, and so I
worked with another guy, I had a sneaker idea. And just I
was able to use that to leverage how I think about selling,
how I think about customers, who I would reach out to in the
GSB network. Outside of that, the only thing I really did
was my second year, I started the speaker series through the
CES which was called the Consumer Product Founders Series,
and it was probably more selfish than anything because I
knew I wanted to be in consumer products, and I just needed
to reach out to as many people from the GSB
[inaudible] brought them in. I think we had to bring in like
10 or 11 speakers in over a few months. So that was a really
useful thing for me. I am still in touch with a handful of
them, and they have been advisors for me. I don't have
really any regrets from the GSB. I think I did a lot of
things I wanted to do. And it's one of those unique times
where you can kind of learn whatever you want to learn and
[inaudible] time whenever you want to. I did two things
differently. One would be potentially just putting a stake
[inaudible] earlier what I wanted to do. I kind of came
back. I came first year at the GSB not
[inaudible] the start up, go back to private equity, go back
to sports, do whatever. But then second year, I started
realizing I want to be in consumer products and so I started
to open
[inaudible]. And it was much easier to have conversations
with alums, with fellow classmates, whatever in terms of
saying this is where I want to go. And the other thing which
has nothing to do with startup or anything is like I wish I
would have just played more tennis, played more basketball,
hung out more because the second you get out, the second you
think of a startup, there is so much to do and so little
time for anything else. So take advantage of being there.
I think Jai had a great point that I mean he said kind of
jokingly, he started the consumer products speakers series
selfishly but - and it doesn't just hold to the GSB, it
holds I think in general in the population. If you do
something to kind of serve what your personal desires and
needs are, you are going to serve a broader population as
well. And he gives you an excuse to reach out to people and
build those deep relationships to become a great foundation
for other things as well. And it doesn't just hold here at
the Business School, I think it holds in life in general. So
what have been your biggest lessons achieved, learned up to
this point? Ilana, you are in the middle --
I would say there are a lot of different ways I could answer
that because I learned lessons every day. But some of the
takeaways I have so far, #1, follow your guide. For me, in
everything I do, there is a point at which you just can't
rationalize a decision anymore and you just have to sort of
let your instinct guide you in terms of whether it's forming
your team or building relationships with like suppliers or
partners, just stuff I do every day. It's really important
to follow my guide because ultimately we are moving pretty
quickly, and I sort of have to just make sure I continue to
push the business forward. And other thing that has been
incredibly important is transparency, and this goes back to
Jai's point with touchy-feely. A lot of what I learned in
touchy-feely, I do use every day. Learning, just being
really open and honest and communicative with everyone that
I work with and just really laying it out on the table has
been absolutely paramount to just sort of building a strong
team and accomplishing what we need to accomplish. So I
would say those are sort of the two things that drive me
every day.
I agree with that stuff. I really thought about this and
there are four things that I think a key lesson I learned.
One is my situation is actually a little different than
these two in the sense that there was a founder who had
developed a product over a year and a half and then he was
bringing me on as his first hire. But in the sense of you
thinking about doing a startup with a cofounder or whatever,
one thing I was told before going into entrepreneurship was
that it's like a marriage and I didn't really believe that,
but the reality is this that John, the founder of
[inaudible], spends more time with me than his wife
probably, and we get lunch every day together, we are in the
office, get every day together. And so one of the biggest
lessons I learned is that underlying values are critical.
Like as long as you guys - we see the same way in terms of
how we want to do business, how we want to build the
company, that's really important. And we are in the process
of recruiting. Right now, we would bring on a third employee
today actually and hopefully a fourth one the next month.
And like as we have gone through the process of meeting a
lot of people, it's been very critical for us to decide
whether that person fits our values and wants to grow the
business in the way we do. And there is a lot of situations
where your values are tested. So I think that's the biggest
lesson I have taken away. Second is that startups are super
volatile, so you better be ready for ups and downs every
day. I mean the way I would like to say is it's ups and
downs but always moving forward. I mean there is a punch in
the stomach every day for random reason. You have just got
to be able to handle it and move forward and realize that if
you have a product you like or a company you believe in that
you are going to move forward and pick out the right to get
things done. Another thing is that if you are doing a
startup, you should try and find a way to have balance in
it. I mean you are taking a giant pay-cut and you are taking
the ability to control your schedule. So realize that
nothing is really that urgent, and you should be able to
find a balance enjoying what you are doing feeling happy,
like
[inaudible] also having a balance with non-startup like
things. And then it was already
[inaudible] things just that the GSB network is incredible.
Actually, I came in through reBloom right when we were about
to launch our fundraising process. And I will tell you that
any GSB alumni e-mail whether they were at a C fund or
institutional fund, individual, angel or whatever, every
single one of them applied to
[inaudible]. And even once
[inaudible] want to take a meeting and nothing to do with
consumer products were responsive and helpful. And if we
look at the people that have eventually invested, I would
say - I mean the large majority of them are GSB alums or
type so GSB somehow. So I think the network is amazing --
So for me, the biggest lesson I have learned over the first
year is that customer feedback or feedback from the outside
world is tricky. It's like dynamite. You can't create a
company without it, you can't a product without it. But if
you use it the wrong way, you will blow your hands off. So
part of that lesson was being really clear on what feedback
you actually want from the people you meet with because
everyone will give you feedback. And so an example of that
is never ask someone what they think of your product, don't
ask them that question. The question that matters is will
they buy it. And if they buy it, how will they use it,
because if you ask them what they think about it, they may
tell you all the things that are wrong with it, all the
things that they think are awesome about it, and none of
those may have any impact on whether or not they buy it. And
so somebody may tell you because you are trying to be
helpful that oh, here are all the critics I have for your
product, and they really are doing from a good place. And
you come out of that meeting thinking your product sucks,
they don't want it. But then if you ask that same person,
well would you but it based on what it currently is, they
might say yes, and you need to know that. And so once we
figured that out, we just stopped asking people what they
thought of our product and just the cut the question to will
you buy it. The other thing is you need to be careful who
you ask for feedback from. So the benefit of the GSB is you
have an amazing network to talk to. That's really tricky
because you might go meet with someone who is
extraordinarily powerful and you go meet with them, and you
get their feedback on your product. And that person tells
you that it doesn't make any sense, they don't think it's
going to have a good market, they don't see how it's going
to go to market, it's going to be too expensive, integration
is going to be an issue. But when you actually start to
think about it, they are not your customer, they have never
been in your space, they have never done anything related to
what you are starting, and so the feedback ended up being
completely useless. Or vise versa, they may tell you it's
completely awesome but all those things still hold so you
get a false/negative or false/positive. So when you meet
with people, you need to be really clear on what their
feedback actually should matter to you. So if it's someone
who is really important, ask them a question that they know
and have credibility in. So if they have been a VP of sales
at some big company, ask them a question about how they are
going to market. Don't ask them about if your product is
going to sell because they are not going to know. If it's
Mark Zuckerberg, don't ask him if he likes your product. Ask
him how he would integrate to his sales platform or
something like that. So those things were very great
lessons. But now that we have learned them, our feedback
sessions and our customer meetings have become a lot more
productive.
[Informal Talk]
Is there anything that you thought was particularly
important that ended up not being so?
[Informal Talk]
I don't know, I mean I am trying to say because I think I am
still learning every day. And for me, to tell you that some
class I took was important, next week it might become super
applicable. So for right now, I mean it's one of those
things where I am moving forward eyes wide open, always
learning. I mean I am finding that certain classes had
become applicable for certain things like I mentioned MGE
touchy-feely or sort of everyday things. But we have to deal
with negotiations, we are taking negotiations, that's
helpful. And I have no doubt that some of the accounting
stuff is --
I mean what about even things in your business? I mean did
you think raising money at a particular time was
particularly important or getting a particular customer?
I mean raising money was important I think. For us, we have
tried to stay pretty balanced with how we approach things
and don't let things affect us too much. So fundraising - we
got done in December, we would like to get done in October/
November but it didn't hold us back. As long as you have
cash in the bank and you feel like you can move forward,
nothing is really stopping us. And so we have had delays and
issues but I don't think there is anything that's surprised
us too much.
I think you guys put too much weight on --
I think -- I don't know, I know sort of I would say through
the GSB and through sort of training and everything like
quant and finance, when you start a business, there can be a
tendency to sort of want to model everything out to the last
detail and make sure that you haven't missed anything. Two
things I would say is understand your market opportunity,
sort of understand your business model or want to think it's
going to be. And you do want to make sure it's viable but
then move on because you could sort of spend all day in
Excel or trying to make every assumption perfect, and the
only way you can make an assumption perfect is to start
running the business and have real data to plug into your
model. It's I would say sort of one thing that was, I don't
know, that I have seen I guess a lot people sort of get
caught up on, I would say make sure not to.
For me, everything I learned in the first year strategy
class. It's just isn't important in your first year
strategy, like the best laid plans, you can think about
competitive advantage, and better entry, and supplier power,
and buyer power, and none of it matters because it's all
going to change dramatically when you are talking to
customers, and it's going to change every week until you
actually hone in on what your business model really is going
to be. And I think what we came to was you don't define
that. All that stuff that you learn in the strategy, you are
evaluating these multibillion dollar companies, and you are
analyzing their strategy. But you don't get to pick that
really, I mean there is only small parts you get to pick.
But a lot of is really reflection of the market you are in.
It's a reflection of the space you are and the technology
you have built. What I would say was most important in terms
of strategy is make sure you are in a big market and make
sure you are in a market that's growing. And if you are in
those things, and you have a product people actually want to
buy because you are solving a real problem, everything else
doesn't matter in the first year. It will matter if you
become really big. But in the first year, the only thing
matters is you have big market, you have growing market and
you have a product people want to buy.
So what have been some big inflection points for you in your
businesses?
[Informal Talk]
So I think the first one for me was in November of my second
year. I pitched WeddingtonWay the first time in a September
session class and just started propelling forward into sort
of working on the idea. In November I cold-called the bunch
of brands in New York and basically said I am the founder of
this like amazing company, and I am going to be in New York,
will they meet with me. They somehow agreed. I got off the
phone these seven brands like in one day and booked a ticket
to New York, and the next week went to New York and met with
all these brands, and got them to agree to sell to my non-
existing company with a non-existing website. So that was
really step one and that was really big because when our
customer's inflection point #2 came to me in April saying
basically they have heard that I was working on something
with bridesmaid dresses, can I help them, I was able to say
yes because I actually had product to sell to them even
though I didn't have a website yet. I would say #3 was
probably being who is over there WeddingtonWay's director of
merchandising agreeing to join this crazy venture turning
one into two. So I was able to tell my investors that our
team size had doubled, which was really exciting. And then,
we launched the beta of our website in November. And from
there, it's been moving at a million miles an hour, whether
it's testing our first Facebook ads and realizing they are
awesome for us, which is really exciting, or launching our
first contest which we did on Monday with the wedding
planning site. It's just sort of - I guess I would say that
what is an inflection point that one of the pieces of advice
have been given by a lot of different people, celebrate
small victories at a startup because you have a lot of ups
and down. So you can have inflection points every day.
I mean with reBloom, some of the stuff that would be more
interesting would be prior to when I started. Right now,
there are a couple of inflection points when John was
developing the product and there are a million. A couple of
[inaudible] raised with friends and family around. So we had
some money in the bank and ended up agonizing over the
decision to buy the URL Rebloom.com and spent $5,000
[inaudible] because it just makes ton more sense to go into
business. And another thing, we spent about a third of this
entire friends and family around on hiring a world-class
packaging design company for the bottle and getting that all
set up. And that was one thing I know he spent a ton of time
debating but one piece of feedback we got from investors and
potential advisors on it for ourselves is that the packaging
looks great, and if you want to - in consumer products
specifically, if you want to sell a premium product, you
need to
[inaudible] like something that targets to mass appeal.
Inflection points as I joined, I mean the product launch
about a month before I joined, and I would say there has
been a bunch of stages in terms of - since I have started, I
mean the big thing for me when I came in this fundraising.
So obviously, that was my major focus coming in. And once we
[inaudible] it's a big inflection point because we were
talking about well, we have x amount in the bank, what are
we going to do, what are we going to do. Then all of a
sudden, we had a lot more in the bank, and it was like okay,
now we can actually think about building this company. The
next inflection point we are sort of still in right now is
that
[inaudible] to build the foundation, we get a new order
management system, we are recruiting, we are building new
office space, all that sort of stuff, things to put
infrastructure in place that you can actually support
growth. And I think we are getting to the point where we are
reaching to the end of that inflection point and the next
one is coming up now which is the idea of sales milestones.
And actually, we have revenue but now it's like how do we
take this business to the next level. So I think I mean -
and that's over the course of nine months, we have been
through a million different inflection points. There were
three major ones that we have seen. So I mean one thing you
will see with the startup is that the landscape shifts
rapidly depending on how you are moving.
We have had inflection points every day. Now, we have had
two major inflection points. The first one was we
bootstrapped for a long time because we wanted to be ready
when we want to go, raise some money, and that was a bad
idea, because the inflection point for us was when we
actually raised money, there is something psychological
about actually having a salary and having other people's
money to spend on the things you need to stand versus your
own. And so the moment we had money in the bank, and there
were enough zeros in the checking account, everybody --
[Informal Talk]
Everyone's felt a lot more comfortable, and our productivity
skyrocketed. And it was just psychological because nothing
else really changed, our burn rate didn't go up all that
much. But there was a perceptible, perceivable shift in the
company's mentality. So I would urge you to raise money. No
matter what it is, raise some amount of money at the
beginning so that you feel like you have a
[inaudible]. The second inflection point for us was first
customer contact. We had designed this great concept on
paper. We hadn't yet programmed anything but we had all the
great PowerPoint slides that showed everything what we were
going to do, and it was fantastic. And then we started
showing it to customers. And that was an amazing experience
because you think you know everything, you know nothing
until customers start telling you about the real pains. And
that feedback will - you cannot create a great company
without it. So our company just from a product perspective
took off once they started taking customer meetings. And we
started doing it on a very, very regular basis, probably
about three meetings a week.
(Audience)
So it's definitely I would say a 'work in progress,' and it'
s probably the first question I have to answer every time I
meet with an investor. So I guess I am probably used to
talking about it. But it's been word of mouth for us, and we
are starting to pay for it as well. But early on, our first
two customers that came in April, one was a GSB classmate,
came up to me in the parking lot of outside little field,
grabbed my hand and said, "We are getting married in August.
I don't know what to do about bridesmaid dresses. I heard
you are doing something. Do you have a solution for me?" And
I was like actually. And since we launched the website, it's
been a combination of like word of mouth and now playing
around with cost per click. And we are in a lucky position
where with Facebook, for example, we can target women with
status engaged. So there is a lot of interesting stuff we
can play around with there. But we are definitely focusing
mostly on online acquisition other than driving word of
mouth.
So our models are little different because we are B2B. So
doing the consumer oriented
[inaudible] doesn't really make any sense. So for us, what's
really worked for us is really just getting through the
network or through relationships or kind of any way we can,
we try and get introductions to the most senior executive we
can at a company or in a target demo. And that person will
generally give us 15-20 minutes because what we are doing
makes sense to them and they need it, then that person will
route us to the appropriate person in the organization. And
that's how not only do we get feedback but we actually build
relationships to get leads for sales.
So just from a consumer product standpoint, if you are
interested in consumer products or eCommerce, customer
acquisitions are very tricky and it's something you need to
be ready to experiment and iterate on. I think the way we
did it when it was launched in May is a lot of word of
mouth, and through the course of May through probably
January is word of mouth and PR.
So probably just from a consumer product stand point of view
and sharing consumer products for eCommerce, customer
acquisition is very tricky and it's something you need to be
ready to experiment and iterate on. I think the way we did
it when it was launched in May it was a lot of word-of-mouth
and through the course of, May through I would call it
January it was word of mouth and PR, so we are in like
DailyCandy and Oprah magazine and few other places where
people saw us and they came to our site. Now right now we
are direct to consumer and we are only available on our
website. And so it's really at this point you know now that
we have money we are turning on the faucet for marketing
spend and customer acquisition is a big goal for 2011. But
it's one where you are not going to lock it day one, you
just need to experiment and figure out, you know what
messaging works for customers, what's bringing through the
site, what's making them convert. And I mean there is a lot
of experimentation so it's you know I know companies like
[inaudible] they have been around for two or three years
they are doing great. They are still trying to figure out.
And so it's one of those things we are yet to keep I mean
it's one thing we would start it generally you iterate and
experiment all the time and everything and that's a huge one
especially in consumer products.
[Audience]
A PR firm, we did yeah so we ended up, we use the PR firm
starting in like July probably June or July, negotiated rate
and I wonder we can do, you will find at the start we can
negotiate a lot of rates with vendors as a startup and so
they gave us that path and ended up using and then they you
know one thing
[inaudible] how many of you have done a history, probably
none of you but it used to be called real launched as
ReBloom Beauty Sleep Drink and the idea there was to get
initial we-chat customers with men and women who tend to
have and more sleep issues tend to be more on to try new
things. We switched recent in natural but the PR firm that
we started working with was very good with Beauty and so we
were able to get placed in things like Marie Claire, Oprah
Magazine and things like that. And that was helpful but I
would say if have been in eCommerce business, customer
acquisition is much more useful when you get online PR, like
newsletters and emails, so people can stick right to your
site.
Yeah.
[Audience]
So my work experience is directly relevant to what I do
everyday. Like you know I spent four years in Enterprise
Sales. And understanding how large enterprises buy stuff is
a very complex art. And so having learned it you know we
don't waste time trying to figure that out and we have heard
from other people in the similar space that they are
throwing themselves against the wall trying to actually get
an interaction inside of large organization. And we are not
dealing with that because we know what we are doing in that
space. That being said I think in hindsight if I could go
back and talk to myself coming on undergrad, I probably
would have tried to take the same job but at an Enterprise
focus to Startup and trying to learn or at least at some
point had taken a job working for a Startup because there
were things that I worked at IBM for example there are
things that I learned at IBM, or that I was used to at IBM
that just don't apply, when you are in your early stage
Startup that you know we are now learning the art.
I will give you two thoughts on that, one is just on my day-
to-day and what I am able to do at ReBloom. I mean I think I
did consulting product, I think that is really valuable
training just in terms to thinking about business judgment,
thinking about how to deal with different parties, how to
build a team, how to build a culture so all this stuff is
very valuable in that plus stuff in the GSB. I will tell you
when I was talking to consumer product companies and doing
recruiting coming out of the GSB, no one cared about the
fact that I was in, if there was a ban there was a place
called Berkshire Partners and both decent places like
everyone cared about Bonobos because that was much more
applicable just because it's a startup and that so in
hindsight I don't know what the right answer is for me in
hindsight I mean I am very happy with the training I got but
potentially having more, had I known earlier I want to do
consumer products or Startups, having more of that in my
resume would have been more helpful, but I mean I think it
sort of depends on sure you are in terms of where you want
to go.
Yeah.
[Audience]
This is an initiative that's very near and dear to my heart
and so it is I can attest. I am - from Miami, Florida and
when I was in school all I wanted to do is go back there and
start my company there. Regardless of what city you are in,
the one thing that I found was that different cities have a
network effect. If you want to start account of your company
and you don't do it here, it's going to be very, very
difficult. The talent is here, the money is here, half of
the customers are leaving really talk to a Startup to work
with, are here. If you are a consumer of tech you know the
people who are most comfortable adopting a new technology
are also here. And so you know it's very difficult to start
something outside of the city where it's not their focus, I
mean this thing goes for LA if you want to media, it
probably should be down there. Want to do finance, New York
is a good place. So those competitive advantages going into
those individual cities, something that as I tried to move
to Miami, I started to run into in a very, very real way and
so I had to actually decide to stay here because of those
advantages.
And he hates it here.
I love it here.
[Audience]
No, I do, I live in Pacific, I live on the beach, it's
fantastic so I get a little site of Miami, it's a little
colder though, but it's nice, I do apply over here.
Yeah I probably have a slightly different perspective, I
think waiting to me probably is been more flexible in terms
of location, we can be in New York for example where the
fashion industry is or there are different places we could
be. I think the choice to be in San Francisco and I guess we
decided that San Francisco really make sense for us. Part of
it is I was here at the GSB for two years and the entire
network I built around while I was building this business is
in the valley. Any question that I have is a coffee away,
and that makes things a lot easier. And as we have inbound
interest from investors I can grab a coffee here and every
investors who are interested in Weddington Way and get to
know them and build a relationship with them I am before
raising my next round of finance. So that just makes sort of
everything a lot more like natural and easier for us on that
front.
And then in terms of talent recruitment I do think it's
valuable being in a location where there are a lot of people
who are interested in working at Startups and understand the
tradeoffs between cash and equity and it's a part of
lifeblood here that isn't necessarily the case in other
places.
We have another 2010 grad, camp down to our office who are
starting a company and he is very deliberately moving back
to Pittsburgh but he is getting this company up and going
and funded here and hoping to pull it back to Pittsburgh so
hopefully we can do it but --.
I will give you a completely different perspective. I chose
my location and nothing to do with professional stuff. It
was more just like, prior to GSB I had taken the best
opportunity and I was in Boston and New York for a while and
I literally, I think that GSB was very good at getting me to
think about what was going to make me happy and content and
I am a very instinct driven person and my instinct was
pointing me towards San Francisco, strong enough to the
point where I turned down three offers in New York and
signed a lease in San Francisco without a job the same week.
And that was to except graduation so I mean for me it was
just like I just felt like the right city. And I figured
everything else fall into place. So I mean I think all the
stuff that this guy said was true and it's turned out to be
great but it was much more this instinct driven, really.
Yeah.
How do you guys prepare for those first cold calls for
today? Are there with investors or with companies that you
got may minor interest, did you talk to people, did you just
kind of fill PowerPoint presentations like actual meeting
with them?
So I just did what I did for 4.5 years. I don't do cold
calls. I deliberately try and get someone into somebody else
because it changes everything you do it that way. But there
were times when we had to do a cold call, in fact one of the
customers that we work with on a regular basis, I cold
emailed, the CIO of Fortune 100 Company and he responded and
we had a meeting and he responded and we had a meeting. That
was very tricky the first line was a GSB grad and that helps
a lot, they will take a meeting. So that's how I start the
meetings, and that's how I get the meetings if you will. I
try and work through someone and that's the most effective
way if we can do it. LinkedIn is a fantastic way to go about
that. So you can see who knows that somebody else and then
if it really comes down to a cold e-mail you really want to
just make yourself seem credible in the first line, and be
really clear with them exactly what you want and if you are
trying to get feedback you should be very clear that you are
just trying to get feedback and not trying to sell them a
product. If you are trying to sell him a product, be clear
in that because if you are kind of vague they don't want to
deal with that. In terms of the meeting I always have
PowerPoint, all my meetins are on WebEx and you know I keep
my PowerPoint as clean and as simple as humanly possible but
at least for us what we are doing a sufficiently complex
where I need a diagram to just convey the concepts fast
enough we can get a lot of time. In terms of time I limit
everything to 20-minute meetings. Anything past that they
start with Nancy they may not take the meeting, and I tell
him upfront in e-mail and I tell him upfront in the actual
meeting that it's going to be 20 minutes so that everybody
is kind of cool. And then I just have really clear idea of
what I want out of the meetings, what are the questions,
what are the three questions I need answered. If it's
feedback, what are the three feedback questions is if I am
trying to sell them on being our partner or paying us for
something you know. There are key questions that I want to
get answered in that direction and trying to get those
answers and everything else is great in the meeting but
that's how I handle.
That I mean two things I would say one is I don't, getting
started I don't think you need to do cold calls. You should
have a network from the GSB and your friends there, take
always more meetings and more interest and with everyone you
talk to they are going to realize they like the video
whatever and they have people they get afraid to and then
you have this nice path of going down just one more
referrals. I think cold calls are pretty difficult in
general. Another thing is just echo some male -- one thing
someone told me in before fundraising which became very true
was if you want money as per advice, if you want to advise
that for money because they will be rather happy to give you
feedback and if they are interested then they might follow
up but the second you come to someone saying hey I am
raising money, do you want to invest, people are just going
to turn away.
I guess from a slightly different perspective I get
mentioned the whole thing, I actually initially had tried to
use my network in a fashion industry to get to their brands
that I wanted to meet with. You know it's just taking too
long because I wasn't ready to wear and the wedding industry
is a little bit different so ultimately I just decided to
this is taking too long, I am just going to call them and
it's sort of knowing your audience so I definitely didn't
mention that I am a business student at Stanford and I am
former buyer from Bloomingdale's starting this awesome
company. So it was really at the end of the day and then it'
s like when you are in that situation, like at least for
that situation I mean you have to like act larger than life
and you have to make them think that you know this is like
the train that's like passing them by and you got to jump on
is sort of I guess my tactic which can be a bit personal.
So that's a great point, so when I threw, I was growing in
the GSB grad in the first line that was to get feedback,
right because when you present yourself as you are new grad
you are young you are trying your feedback people open up
and they will tell you. And they will tell you and they will
give you feedback they will give you advice in the world you
can get a lot of data. When you are actually trying to get a
business relationship off the ground and you really want
meet with them to actually try and build something. Our
first line is not that. Our first line is actually talking
about open source project and as successful point, so we are
legitimate we know they we are credible we have community
behind us we know we are talking about.
I also want to ask you a question I think one of the most
critical skills an entrepreneur can have is in sales and you
obviously had some great training in an organization that
has some of the sales training. What recommendations you
have for people who don't have four years of IBM, and don't
have that sales training how can they figure out I mean is
it entrepreneur you are constantly so.
Yeah so I will give you two things that I think are I will
try and keep it quick. There are a few things. The first is
you need to understand how your customers buy, your
customers go through a buying process and if you are not
sensitive to their buying process, you are just trying to
close a deal. Not only you are going to close a deal you are
going to piss them off and they are not going to talk to you
ever again. And so what that means is your customers go
through a very simple buying process which is okay well what
do I really need, right what am I trying to accomplish what
are my initiatives etc. And if you get to talk to them at
that point when they are trying to figure out what exactly
it is that they are trying to buy or you can help build a
vision around what they actually need, based on the features
that you have built. The second step in the process is once
they kind of know what they need, then it's about okay well
what are my options are, what are the different products I
can buy or the solutions I can implement and that's when you
traditionally do the pitching. And then once you go through
that process then after they have seen everything and they
have figured out if you are something that does make sense
for what they need then you are going to closing mode. What
everybody talks about is always be closing that I said don't
list that. I hate that because customers don't react well to
that. And then once you are in close mode we really clear
with your customer that you are in close mode and try and
close the deal. But I can probably go in for an hour on how
you actually do that but it's you know when you started
something complicated you said hey listen can we close this.
When can you buy what you need to make the purchase and
that's enough early on. The next thing is be brutal with
your customers or at least your customer management and that
listen if your customer is too small or your customer doesn'
t have budget or your customer is planning on buying it in
like 18 months stop talking of it. Just because it's these
great brands doesn't mean you should waste all this time
trying to get them to close with you if they don't budget
around, timeframe you are talking about, person they don't
really have a need. You are too busy so once you realize
that someone doesn't have budget, authority, needs and time
or timeframe move on to the next deal otherwise you are
going to waste your time. Second to last thing, is start at
the top, if you are selling to an organization start as high
as you possibly can start in the organization. I think for
rookies in sales it is too easy to convince yourself that oh
I can get a meeting with this guy at a bottom so I am just
going to do that, because the senior person won't want to
talk to me and you start talking to that person what happens
in an organization is at that low level person might give
you a lot of great feedback, but they will generally believe
that the are the authority on the purchase and they
generally aren't. And once you build a relationship with
them they might feel that they should be owning the
relationship with you and if you try and get a meeting with
someone in a different department or higher than them they
might feel like you are going over the head and so you might
have a political assurance on your head, which becomes a
really big problem when your deal stalls. Now you can't talk
to anyone else in trying to save the deals. And so deals can
drag on in this case. The worst case scenario is you might
lose a deal and you never you are going to know you lost it
through talking to the wrong person. If you needed to talk
that person can route you to the right person the moment he
knows what you are selling. He is like oh, this is really
interesting I want to learn more about it, Bob is the guy
who is in-charge of this. And you meet with Bob and you did
in one meeting, and now because Bob is going to write it
down to one of his guys, he might write it down one of his
guys, you might end up at the bottom, but now because you
build a relationship with everybody on the way down if the
deal stalls you can work the way back up. And the last thing
is the most important thing a sales person can do is not the
social, it's not be like fun person hanging out with, I am
having a good pitch like all that stuff is pretty commodity
everyone knows that, the most important thing is being able
to answer a customer objection. When a customer says oh I
don't want product, it's too expensive. And just go okay
when customers tell you all the reasons they won't buy a
product, what they are really doing is they are testing
their understanding of what you are selling and whether or
not they need it. So when they say oh it's too expensive, oh
it's too big, oh it's slow whatever, you want to flash that
idea. You want to understand where they are coming from or
why do say it's too expensive. Well may be it's because they
don't have budget, may be it's because they are comparing
two different products. May be it's because they are
comparing to some of the things completely irrelevant. You
want to understand that stuff so that then you can formulate
a response. Like well I understand you think it's too
expensive, but if you consider this cost of building
yourself which is what you are alternative really is this is
actually price. And so you can bond to a lot of customer
objections and if you do that your sales will go up. And by
the way Harvard has a study that actually proved that that
was the most effective thing for successful -
So there is just sales class.
[Inaudible]
I can start we had a really big obstacle. We hit a bit of
road block once about five months ago. We were getting a lot
of really high quality feedback, we are meeting with all our
target customers and we were just getting really high
quality feedback and based on that feedback, we realized
that the product we were planning on building and taking the
market had a business model flaw to it. And we agonize what
we are going to do, right because we saw this is not going
to work the way it's currently architected and the way we
are going to have to go to the market. So we had to pivot
the product. In a business school classes they will talk
about how companies pivot and they will say that you know
all this feedback you should pivot if you realize that the
market - it's all hindsight on how you pivot and you thing
the companies are pivoted and all worked out beautifully.
When you are pivoting it is terrifying. It is the most
difficult you have gone through, we won't even show how we
survive with pivot because tax to that was when we raise
money, we were optimistic when we raise money and so we
raised money based on the fact that oh yes here is how
things will play out. And when you are pivot you essentially
you are taking three steps back and there were good steps
had to be taken, but suddenly you know your financial doesn'
t really line up with the rule up anymore so now they are
like well how do we actually finance ourselves through the
process we now know we have to go through all over again
with the new product. It was very, very difficult, so my
only advice is don't be scared to pivot, because you are
going to have to if you actually have a problem with your
business, with your business model and when you are raising
your mutual set of, your initial brand of capital make sure
you are raising enough to survive a pivot or two because
chances are you will go through one.
I mean there is a lot of obstacles we face I am trying to
think of a specific one that might be helpful. The question
the one thing is when we are fundraising we receive the term
sheet from a well-known seat funding area that was pretty
onerous in terms of just a lot of terms that we would never
want to sign and so as an obstacle it was kind of well here
is a term sheet it was fundraising but something we don't
feel good about versus well we have some cash that they want
to keep fundraising and there is a risk of losing this big
round. And I think that's where I go back to one of the
things I think I found has been the most important is having
your values in line and so like John and I talked about it
extensively and you know we get to the point where we are
like you know what we don't want to sign something we feel
uncomfortable with and so we would rather you know as long
as the underlying confidence that we have a product that
will work and we have a business that we can build. We don't
want to go forward with the term sheet that didn't make
sense for us. And so we have actually decided not to sign it
which is a big obstacle and big decision and we are
uncomfortable with going out with their own term sheet and
raising last or whatever another term sheet happen to come
in with that grade but I mean that was one where I just
think it is any obstacles or testing your values and so as
long as you know you and your cofounder your employee they
were online and they are building a culture of people or
sort of thinking along the same core values I think that's
really important. In terms of obstacles you know challenges
we face everyday I think one of the biggest ones is just try
to juggle a million things. There is no end in terms of
things to do and so one thing that I have found very helpful
recently, it goes back to just be it, I will never take a
class with Joe Patterson a classmate of my did and told me
about this 2X2 that he uses in terms of trying to prioritize
things where on one axis is not important is important and
on the top part it's not urgent, urgent. And so I have a
white board over my expert, where now I have that and like
urgent important I am going to take care of today, all the
other stuff can wait and that's helped us to get through one
of the biggest challenges which is just the fact that two
people try and do a million things.
[Informal Talk]
Yes, it's a hard question to answer I guess because we are
still in very early stage so I think there are lots of
challenges I don't know what the biggest one is you know one
thing that we are going through right now is transitioning
from super lean bootstrap mode to spending to grow. And just
getting comfortable with growing our team, increasing our
burden and that is just something you know a part of it is
just that's where having a team composed of people who have
like faith in the business and really are passionate about
the opportunity and what we are building, brining in
contractors everyone we work with is really like passionate
about the opportunity, I mean that's a really important
piece of you know I guess just to spending into growth for
us I think. Because it's you know you are constantly taking
leaps of faith. And then, I mean we have lots of little
challenges we went to New York at the end of January to, it
was to meet with members of the media who had reached out to
us, who were interested in covering Weddington Way to meet
with suppliers and you know we had while we were there we
had one of the meetings we were most excited about with
someone really senior at the magazine like they canceled on
us last minute. It was just like you know that stuff that
happens all the time and you have to deal with it and they
ended up making introduction for us to and editor in LA who
is actually the editor we should be talking to anyway, and
so it was like trying to like you know put everything in
perspective and realize what would the goal of that meeting
have been and it would have been an introduction to that
editor so may be we just saved ourselves an hour while in
New York and we can do something else at that time and focus
on the fact that we now have this other contact. So it's
just I mean there are always big and little things and it's
just a matter of like continuing to like push forward and
just you have to really believe in what you are doing to
whatever the obstacle is to keep pushing forward otherwise
you won't be able to get up in the morning.
[Informal Talk]
So equity is really important, it's a really important thing
I mean you know something like we have talked to lot about
is you have to be smart with equity and who you give it to,
but generous when you find the right people. Because you
want the people joining you to be not employees but owners
of the company with you, and so that's been I would say
number one and that's you know other than that it's you know
figuring out I mean we have conversations that Jay was
talking about like negotiating with PR firms in the process
of hiring a PR firm right now, with contractors we have
employed you know we sort of always talk to them it's very
important for us if the people who work for us makes it sure
that they are being compensated appropriately and so just
having it really open conversation with everyone we work
with about what we can and cannot afford and making sure
that we are partnering with people who are excited about
what we are doing and sort of buying and really you know we
come to understand as we don't want people to be doing work
for us where they feel like we are sort of just completely
under compensating them because you are not going to get the
best out of them, so really just having open communication
with people you employ and making sure they are sort of on
board with what you are doing.
[Informal Talk]
So, we have a law firm that we use in the valley called
[inaudible] which does a lot of financing and so, when John
was starting the company we use Event Corporation and all
sort of documents that need to have upfront and basically
the agreed to differ expenses until we raised around and I
think that's sort of the standard for those law firms that
are pretty expensive and we tend to use them only when we
need to because the hourly rates are pretty high but they
are very useful firm incorporation for trademark stuff for
financing and all that sort of stuff. Now that we have money
and now that we are looking at milestones to kind of take to
the next level of growth, we are also exploring legal
options from consumer product standpoint, we sell adjustable
there are certain issues that potentially come up in terms
of conditions claims you may, all that sort of stuff and so
we are in the early stages of that and I think the one thing
we learned is having a good learning is very helpful
especially getting a lot of documents then we had one letter
from another company that was you know claim that we have
taken a trademark which was wrong but we had a very strong
lawyer that sent them a letter that basically shut them up
and took a lot of work up our plate that we wouldn't be able
to do. So I think there is lot of value there and I don't
know we would say going forward but it is like we are trying
to leverage much advice as we can and I don't think we will
have anyone on retainer per se but just having good contacts
would be helpful.
[Informal Talk]
I do not know, I did not use attorney at all. I mean that is
very much like, I liked them a lot we got along he gave me
an offer, I mean to a lot of point he gave me an offer I was
excited to join the team and he was excited to have me and
that was -- lawyer.
If I could just quick comment on that so, one of our
advisers gave us great advice on seeking legal advice that
we took to heart and I now see the wisdom in that advice.
Our first advice was wait as long as humanly possible before
you engage a lawyer as an early stage start, until you
actually have any kind of contract that you design, don't
engage with a lawyer because it's an expense and it is a
distraction as well like you will spend time with lawyer and
you know even if it's just three hours, those three hours
you should be spending, making sure you are actually in a
company because incorporating something that's never going
to sell anything is you are --. So we waited as long as
possibly could until we were actually about certain new
customer and I start doing some work for them that we
actually started incorporate till we get the legal
protection, that's really what is there for. They will give
you legal protection. The second thing is you know pick the
best partner you can get at the law firm and that will also
be by referral. If you just call up, well it's not senior
just call us then and if we can last and try and get you
know somebody to help you, you might not get the best
person, work your network to try and get the best partner
you can because they are going to give you advice when you
need it, specifically around fundraising because they see
more deals in venture capital. And if they ask for equity
it's a small amount of equity, it is a drop in the bucket
you know compared to the much of investment business.
So, I guess I mean I will just answer that quickly I guess I
am sort of probably in line with what Alex said and may be
slightly counter so the waiting is long as you can I guess
may be I paid for like our first sort of orders on my
personal credit card to our suppliers and that was the point
at which I realized I should probably be incorporating. So
that might have been waiting as long as possible but on the
other hand I would say just on the flip side if you are
looking to build something big you want to make sure you are
doing it right. So for me like my lawyers know where I stand
and I am not going to be talking to them on the phone two
hours a week, but when it's important I am going to involve
them and if it costs a little extra fine you know just
because I am trying to build something and don't want to
screw it up and it exist for a reason, so I think there is
like a balancing act there, of making sure you are being
smart about building something scalable.
[Informal Talk]
Yes, so in terms of fundraising.
Yes.
So, we didn't use them to actually meet investors and get to
that point but once we have term sheet in place we used, we
help them, we use them in terms of like our
[inaudible] relatively you said to close but then the lead
investor also had a lawyer too, so that kind of balanced
that up.
[Informal Talk]
I took out a loan in May. I hadn't borrowed against 100% of
my tuition so I have been living off of a student alone at
3% which is pretty chip financing.
I did the same thing, I mean I knew I was going to start a
company at a school so I borrowed also unless I can get --
money need them and kept all my cash, I didn't pay for any
school out of my savings, all 3% loans which is back for
money, and also my wife works which is really, really good.
One of my favorite quotes to Josh Greenberg, somebody asked
him this question at one time he says when your students
look around he says for me when a kid is growing I could
possibly find when she had earning potential and married
her.
[Informal Talk]
[Audience]
That totally depends on the business.
I raised 300K so far. My commitment is the week of
graduation we are 30K from classmates so I built the website
with $12,000.
And bootstrap you need a bunch of different things, right
you actually have money to do it but you don't have to --
one order rates of friends and family member but a lot of
people are just trying to raise what they need right away
just to get the foundation place. I know John raised a
couple of hundred K in friends and family and was very cost
conscious in terms of getting into a product launch and then
we obviously raised more but it took him a long way.
We didn't pay ourselves for four months and then raised
$200,000.
Okay guys we have 10 minutes left. Can you impart your
wisdom on the students here, what advice you would have for
them, may be even going from the good advice that you have
got, what his resume did with you that
[inaudible] you want to pass on to this next generation?
I guess I sort of spoke to it a little bit. But I think the
best advice I could give is use your time at the GSB to take
as many risks as possible. Even I was thinking about when
Alex was entering the sales question I mean if you don't
have sales like a lot of it, it is part of a strategy and a
part of it is gusto. And just use the time, I did in my
second year I did, I gave a talk as part of top 10 for our
class and so it's not just in business but we are taking
personal risk like push yourself outside your comfort zone,
get comfortable with that whether you end up doing a start
up or working at a large enterprise like the sort of being
comfortable, sort of pushing yourself outside your comfort
zone and taking risks, it's something you have the luxury of
tiers at school to doing all sorts of different ways.
I mean I have a bunch of things I could say that were
helpful to me. I have probably said a few of them. I mean
one, find some with underlined values to work within as
super critical. Two from the GSB's first year especially for
anybody regardless we on go and say take MGE and take that
you feel in for people who wanted to start ups to 356. And
another thing that from an academic standpoint, I will take
a lining start ups with the markets with Racliff and Barnet
and four steps to the epiphany from the books they had us
read and that's one of the best books I have ever read on
entrepreneurship and building a business in the right way
using customer development. We have heard these questions
around obstacles and inflexion points and I think we have to
realize it's not like a business school case we look back
and there is obvious obstacles, and obvious inflextion
points. I mean every single day you
[inaudible] every single day, there are some new challenges,
there are new inflexion points and obstacle and just like
realize that if you believe in your product, you believe in
your company you know you will get over those barriers,
roadblocks and you just got to keep moving forward. And then
two peace of advice that were extremely helpful for me when
I was making decision one thing is that all great
entrepreneurs wanted to do is they mitigate risk whether it'
s business decisions they make or whatever. And I think if
you think about this in terms of your career, one great way
to mitigate risk is got the GSB and so like I think everyone
here is in a good position to start a company because you
already know if it doesn't work so what you have the GSB and
whatever else you do before it fall back on. For me, that
was a huge deal. I actually don't feel that much stress even
though we have so a long way to go to make it happen. And
then the final thing is the idea of just doing it and it's
so clich? that the reality is like one thing I found is that
you are so much more ready for this than you think you are
and I had enough excuses, I was thinking about raising a
search fund, nice things with the start up stuff talking
people from my private equity firm, talking another people
like well, why don't I try and do this for a couple of
years. One of the offers I turned in New York was a big
company that was ready to go Pit Salt it's just actually got
some dams on shortly after I can go but I mean I think my
idea there was I go there, I get more credibility and then I
spent off and start something but the reality was ready to
do it now, why not just do it. I think that's --
Yeah, if you are a first year student and you think you will
at some point want to start a remotely tech oriented company
you have to take the Andy Ratcliffe go by the class. If you
don't, you are throwing away your in the end.
[Informal Talk]
Yeah, you have to round zero that one. So that is the best
class and the most applicable class I took related to tech
and if you can't get into it or use decide to not take my
advice, make sure you get the reading list and read all the
books Four Steps to Epiphany is the first book they read.
There is another one called Crossing the Chasm. There is
another one called Innovator's Solution which is also as a
local Innovator's Dilemma, both are good reads. So if you
can't take a class, read the books. If you do take the class
and if you do not go to lunch with Andy Ratcliffe twice a
week, like he offers, you are also wasting your money as the
GSB. So strong words, I also echo Touchy-feely. Touchy-feely
is a thing we use every single day because it is hard sort
of company and those skills are used every single day when
my partner and I are having problems.
For those of you who are alums that is available now through
our Lifelong Learning as well.
Yeah. So fantastic class, also I will, I will say if you do
have a tech bent, I love you but I would not take your 56. I
do not recommend it. It is the process you go through does
not lend itself properly to the process you will have to go
through for a new tech concept. It's too rigid and too
linear process and that's just not how tech companies are
started.
[Informal Talk]
I think if it's -- twice so I really don't recommend it. And
if you are in second year or you will eventually be second
year or you are just not a GSB student, one advice I was
giving immediate I did appreciate when I was a student and
now I appreciate it. You don't have to start a company the
moment you graduate. There is this pressure when you are
here at Stanford especially here at Stanford that you have
to start a company. Of course, because there is Facebook
down the street and your friend just launched a social
networking company that's being valued at like $9 billion
over like two weeks. So you have to do the same thing. You
don't and if you give yourself the pressure that you have to
start a company, you will make bad decisions and you will
take a concept that may be isn't good market, maybe it's
not, maybe it's super competitive so you don't give yourself
that pressure. And now, if you do have a concept that you do
want to start at a school you will never be more ready than
you are today. The concept of let me go work for a start up
and you just put because I want to learn this that I need to
know. Trust me, you will learn enough on the job and if it
really is something that you need to know and you don't
know, you can hire someone. So there is no need to wait if
you do have thing that's really compelling. And the last
thing is your idea, your idea sucks. Right, accept it, it's
not a secret, if you go talk to people, they are not going
to steal your idea and go public tomorrow. It's not going to
happen. So don't keep it a secret because I promise you
whatever you have right now is wrong. It is completely and
you are not going to know it until you actually start
sharing it with people. So this was steal concept.
Absolutely great. Only because there is two minutes left and
I have a chance to kind of line up a couple of pieces of
advice and I totally echo a lot of what these guys say. But
I mean if you are a student, you have a great opportunity to
become an expert in something and these guys eluded to it. I
mean Alex is right people what tell you things that shouldn'
t be telling you when you are a student I mean absolutely
positively leverage the hell out of that and be calling
people and becoming an expert in something and Jay eluded
putting a stake in the ground in terms of what our interests
are people do a much better job responding to a specific
request than to I am really trying to find a pool company to
work with or sort that if you start with something you are
going to iterate your way to where it is you want to be. So
even if it's in artificial constraint and you can probably
do two artificial constraints simultaneously but there is a
lot of value and really having something specific for folks
to respond to. And Alex come in and you don't need to start
a business right out of school anecdotally the larger number
of our alums who have started businesses have done so two to
three years out frequently and particularly if you are
coming from a Consulting Investment Banking background, you
haven't been in the industry, you haven't seen where there
is a really big need, to find that big market, that growing
market that Alex talks about. So if you get down and you
will find that bigger market so there is certainly an
argument for waiting a couple of years and there is a good
argument for doing it earlier rather than later. I wonder I
think I will just lob out to court force and the other room
I was kind of bumped as this is the same time as mine. But
he has launched this really cool program called the Runway
Project part of innovation and diverse and I think he is
going to come back spring quarter but if those of you who
are thinking about wanting to do something of the prior but
aren't too sure what. I encourage you to look another Runway
Project, they are trying to use this project shed model of
putting smart people in a room to find that big market, to
find that big idea and then develop the idea and launch it.
So I mean it's an answer I get so I would have so many
students in my office saying I want to start something but I
don't know what.
[Audience]
It's called the Runway Project where innovation and diverse
which is funded by Eric Smith and of course, that they are
not taping his workshop but if you take a look at his
website, he just launched the first class in February, he is
going to launch another one in August but applications are
due I think by April. But hopefully he will be coming back
spring quarter to talk. Well, thank you. Thank you for
chatting with my friends.
[Applause]